amen and they just made it through the
storm down there in louisiana storm
delta
and that's where we're at now we got
airlines sponsoring the storms
what that's how it is now this next
storm brought to you by
entergy this next storm brought to you
by
taskrabbit here's a storm
here's a tornado brought to you by
bratches candies
do you like branches get you some
and next thing you know your house is on
its ass
that's what it's coming to it's coming
to
natural disasters sponsored by
companies okay
here's your craft macaroni and
earthquakes brother
you want some of that rabies oh this
strand
it's fierce it's just
as fierce as the new spotify
that's i'm just telling you what's next
guys
it's all for sale now it's all for sale
but i'll say this about louisiana and
i'm hyped up i'll tell you i'm hyped up
you know and i'm tired of sometimes you
know i'm not tired of anything but
sometimes i'm hyped up and sometimes i'm
not
sometimes i have a different mood and
i'm hyped up today
you know we're supposed to have a
trucker and we don't have a trucker
we're supposed to have a trucker and we
don't have a trucker
okay so that's where i'm at i'm handling
it
i'm moving forward
but dude every time i'm afraid to even
call people in louisiana anymore when i
call home man everybody's hiding from a
storm
oh what's going on we under a blanket
right now
we got 40 of those weighted blankets you
know we riding it out
yeah we having a party we just you know
we got
five handles of tito's
you know hell the dog's having a damn
jello shot right now
we out here at my cousins we riding it
out
we driving austin that i feel like the
only thing
living in louisiana is basically like
playing hide and go seek with the
weather that's it
it's just like you and mother nature in
a game of red rover
that's what's going on when you're
living down there in louisiana on the
gulf coast
we packing everything up
i'm like y'all just get y'all just moved
in yeah we moving out
the rain's coming
oh man bless you guys i'm glad you guys
made it through it
i'm glad you guys made it through it man
and thanks for the update and um
and you know it gets me remember about
four
you that rain riley i do
it's cool huh yeah that's it's a lot
that's a lot man that's cool
that's one thing as different man about
living here instead of living in
california
predominantly anyway he's just feeling
that weather calm
in california if there's weather you
feel like it's part of a movie set
you're just
because it's always the same the
weather's always nice so you get
something a little different
you feel like somebody just cute it was
part of like the producer just sent it
or director just
send in the uh let's do five mile five
mile per hour winds
yeah can you raise the wind and send a
bird
let's send up send two birds yeah it's
spring
that's what it feels like out there in
california if something comes through
that it's all designed
but here you get a natural piece of
something
and it's nice man you remember that
there's a bigger director out there
there's mother nature's out there
and that bad is union and she is
uh
she's doing whatever she wants now
because she has tenure and she's not
worried about getting fired she gets a
two-hour lunch break
even though she only has a five-hour
work day so but
anyway uh thanks for that good afternoon
and other times
thanks for watching that video you just
saw i mean it was okay
but the next video you can watch could
be way better what if you watch a video
right now that changes
your life well you could watch this one
or watch this one
watch this one watch this one watch this
one